Dracula is a slave of ransom belonging
to Gaga the daughter whom in the 35th
year of Nebuchadnezzar from Akinori for
the third of our money and eight shekels
she bought recently he has instituted in
action saying thus I am the son of a
noble ancestor of the family of Belle
Romani who have joined the hands in
matrimony of Samus medomak the son of
Naboo Nadine AK and the woman casado
the daughter of Akinori even I in the
presence of the high priest the nobles
and the judges of nabonidus king of
Babylon they pleaded the case and
listened to their arguments in regard to
the obligation and servitude of said
Barack EO from 35th year of
Nebuchadnezzar to the seventh year of
nabonidus he had been sold for money and
had been put in pledge and as the dowry
of Noctor the daughter of gaga had been
given afterward
nuta had alienated him by a sealed
contract in exchange for a house and
slaves to zamana Deane her son and to
Adeena her husband and had given him
they the judges read the evidence and
thus said to parochial proved to us nine
noble ancestry Braccio retracted his
former statement saying twice if I run
away from the house of my master but
many people were present and I was seen
I was afraid and I said accordingly I
was the son of a noble ancestor my
citizenship exists not I am the slave of
ransom of Gaga neuter her daughter
received me as her dowry Noctor
alienated me by a sealed contract and to
za mama nadine Hasan and Adina her
husband gave me in exchange and after
the death of gagarin Luba
to et Murdoch ballad for silver I was
sold I am a slave go now pronounce
sentence about me
[Music]
the high priest the nobles and the
judges heard the evidence and restored
BER archaeal to his condition as a slave
of ransom
you
[Music]
you